hey guys welcome to another exciting
video by simply learn
in this video we bring you the top 10
computer hacks of all time
but before we begin if you're new here
and haven't subscribed already
make sure to hit the subscribe button
and the bell icon for interesting tech
videos every day
let's see what we have at number 10 from
april 27 2007
estonia the european country faced a
series of cyber attacks that lasted for
weeks
this happened when the estonian
government decided to move the bronze
soldier
from talon center to a less prominent
military cemetery located on the city's
outskirts
unprecedented levels of internet traffic
took down estonian banks online services
media outlets broadcasters and
government bodies
botnets sent massive waves of spam and
vast amounts of automated online
requests
according to researchers the public
faced ddos attacks
there were conflicts to edit the english
language version of the bronze soldiers
wikipedia page as well
although there is no confirmation russia
is believed to be behind these cyber
attacks that largely crippled the
estonian society
let's now move on to the next attack on
december 23
2015 several parts of ukraine witnessed
a power outage
and this was not a typical blackout it
was indeed the result of a cyber attack
information systems of three energy
distribution companies in ukraine were
compromised
it is the first known victorious cyber
attack on apar grid
it is said that here hackers sent out
phishing emails to the power companies
30 substations were switched off and
about 230
000 people were left in the dark for
about one to six hours
us investigators believed that
russia-based hackers were responsible
for this
experts have warned that other countries
could also be vulnerable to such attacks
let's see what we have at number eight
in the year 1999
a cyber attack cost a 21 day shutdown of
nasa computers
unbelievable isn't it the hacker was
none other than the then 15 year old
jonathan james
he first penetrated u.s department of
defense division's computers
and installed a back door on its servers
this allowed him to intercept more than
a thousand government emails
including the ones containing usernames
and passwords
this helped james steal a piece of nasa
software and crack the nasa computers
that support the international space
station
which cost the space exploration
agencies forty one thousand dollars
as systems were shut down for three
weeks he was the first person to carry
out a computer hack against the american
space agency
let's now move on to the next attack in
late november 2014 there was a leak of
confidential data from the film studio
of sony pictures
information about sony pictures
employees their emails copies of the
then unreleased sony films
future propositions and other crucial
data were leaked
this cyber attack was carried out by a
hacker group named guardians of peace
so what did the hackers want well they
demanded that sony withdraw its then
upcoming movie the interview
this movie was a comedy story line to
assassinate the north korean leader kim
jong-un
sony then decided to cancel the film's
theatrical release due to the threats at
cinema screening the movie
it is indeed hard to trace the roots of
a cyber attack
in this case after evaluation the u.s
intelligence officials arrived at the
theory that the attack was in a way
related to the government of north korea
however north korea had denied the same
moving on to our number six
in december 2006 tjx the u.s retailer
company
identified that 45.6 million debit and
credit card details were stolen
this happened from one of its systems
over 18 months by an unknown number of
intruders
it was one of the first largest ever
cyber attacks involving the loss of
personal data
as a result banks in the affected
regions had to reissue and block
thousands of payment cards a group of
hackers did this
albert gonzalez being the mastermind the
group was from miami the place where the
tjx heist was believed to have
originated
reports said that the tjx data breach
occurred because of
weak web encryption at two of its
marshall stores in miami
next moving on to our top five let us
see what we have at number five
the year 2010 witnessed the discovery of
the deadly computer worm stuxnet
this malware's motive was unlike any
other usual cyber attacks
it aimed at destructing the equipment
the computers controlled
stuxnet came with the deadly purpose of
damaging iran's nuclear infrastructure
it infected more than 200 000 computers
including 14 industrial sites and a
uranium enrichment plant in iran
stuxnet initially spread via microsoft
windows and targeted siemens industrial
control systems
although it was discovered only in 2010
it is believed to have been silently
sabotaging iran's nuclear facilities
it was one of the first discovered
malware that was capable of hampering
hardware systems
it largely damaged the centrifuge of the
iranian reactors
this is believed to be a cyber weapon
created by the u.s and the israeli
intelligence
although there is no documented evidence
or acceptance by either of the countries
for the same
moving on to number four in the year
2014
home depot was the victim of one of the
deadliest cyber attacks
56 million payment cards were
compromised along with 53 million
customer email addresses stolen
this security breach happened from april
to september 2014.
criminals were believed to have used a
third-party vendor's username and
password to
enter the perimeter of home depot's
network
the attackers were then able to deploy
custom built malware on its
self-checkout systems in the us
and canada moving on to our top three
as you might be aware the playstation
gaming system is one of sony's most
popular products
unfortunately in april 2011 sony
executives witnessed abnormal activity
on the playstation network
this resulted in the compromise of
approximately 77 million playstation
users accounts
and prevented users of playstation 3 and
playstation portable consoles from
accessing this service
this forced sony to turn off the
playstation network on april 20th
on may 4th sony confirmed that
personally identifiable information
from each of the 77 million accounts had
been exposed
the outage lasted for 23 days sony
released almost daily announcements
concerning the system outage
in the end sony is believed to have
invested approximately 170 million
dollars
to improve the network security to
investigate the attack and to cover the
expenses of caring for the consumers
that had been affected
let's now move on to the next attack at
number two in may 2017 one of the most
dangerous cyber attacks took place it
was known as the wannacry ransomware
attack
caused by the wannacry crypto worm the
victims were the users that used the
unsupported version of microsoft windows
and those who hadn't installed the new
security update
this did not take place through phishing
like other attacks but
through an exposed vulnerable smb port
the attack originated in asia and then
eventually spread across the globe
in a day more than 200 000 computers
were infected across 150 countries
the wannacry crypto worm locked the
users out of the targeted systems
and encrypted their data the users were
asked for a ransom of 300 to 600
which had to be paid via bitcoin in
exchange for their data
this attack took a toll on both private
and government organizations
it resulted in damages from hundreds of
millions to billions of dollars
in a matter of few days the emergency
patches released by microsoft halted the
attack
also the discovery of a kill switch
prevented the infected computers from
spreading the crypto worm
security experts in a few countries
believed that north korea was behind
this attack
and finally let's see what we have at
number one
more than two decades ago in march 1999
the melissa virus a mass mailing macro
virus was released
it targeted microsoft word and outlook
based systems and created considerable
network traffic
melissa virus infected computers via
emails
the email would look like an important
message well yes it was fake
if the recipient opens the attachments
in the mail and downloads the document
and then opens it with microsoft word
a virus was released on their computers
this would then mass mail itself to the
first 50 people in the victims contact
list
and then disable multiple safeguard
features on microsoft word and microsoft
outlook
this began spreading like a wildfire
across the internet
david l smith released the virus the
virus cost nearly 80 million worth of
damages
it did not steal data or money however
it caused a havoc
almost 1 million email accounts were
disrupted worldwide
agencies were overloaded and some had to
be shut down
entirely and internet traffic in some
locations were
slowed down so with that we come to the
end of this video on the top 10 computer
hacks of all time
do you agree with our list if you're
aware of any other great interesting
computer hacks in history
do let us know in the comment section
below thank you so much for being here
and do watch out for more videos from us
until then keep learning and stay tuned
to simply learn